[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 18 janvier voici
les titres elle est la première commune
yvelinoise à être labellisé carrières
sous poissy fait partie désormais des
villes engagées contre le sida une
distinction pour souligner les actions
mises en place au niveau local
la remise du label a été effectué ce
matin en mairie
l'appel à projets est ouvert jusqu'au 31
janvier le plan france roland soutient
les projets locaux des associations de
protection animale une enveloppe d'un
million d'euros est allouée dans la
région l'occasion pour nous de découvrir
rk qui recueille des chiens abandonnés
venus de métropole et des départements
d'outre-mer et plus létal affiche
d'animal de cyril dion sortie en
décembre le militant écologiste vipul
and to madness varane était à poissy le
week-end dernier pour une projection du
film l'illinois est venu échanger avec
les habitants sur la question de la
biodiversité
tennis également dans cette édition avec
la victoire du saint germanois arthur
rinderknecht au premier tour de l'open
d'australie
[Musique]
direction donc carrières sous poissy
pour débuter ce journal la commune s'est
vue remettre aujourd'hui le label villes
engagées contre le sida une distinction
pour rendre plus visible la lutte contre
le vih michael et demi d'euros
c'est une grande première pour une
commune des yvelines ce mardi 18 janvier
carrières sous poissy a reçu le label
villes engagées contre le sida cette
distinction remise par l'association
élus locaux contre le sida pour but
d'accompagner la politique de la ville
sur le vih ce sont des politiques
publiques qui vont être déclinés sur le
champ des ressources humaines sur le
champ de la prévention sur le champ de
l'éducation sur le champ 2
secteur des affaires périscolaires mais
c'est aussi et surtout un
concrètement un engagement de
l'administration communale de porter une
politique de santé publique de lutte
contre le sida ce label a été créé en
2011 avec une idée à l'époque rendre
plus visible la lutte des collectivités
contre le vih chaque commune peut
demander ce label le dossier est ensuite
examiné par l'association si on ne parle
pas du vih est bien à carrières sous
poissy comme ailleurs beaucoup de gens
vivent avec ce virus est souvent sont
dans une espèce de honte n'osent pas le
dire et donc c'est important que cette
ville disent 'vous savez nous on est là
on vous accueille on est à vos côtés il
faut pas se battre contre les personnes
qui fait que le vih il faut se battre
contre contre se contre ce virus et donc
le message de deux carrières sous poissy
est extrêmement importante à carrières
sous poissy ce label sera présent
visuellement en entrée on sentit l'huile
sur des panneaux
rendre plus facile la mobilité au
quotidien c'est le but de cette start-up
basé aux mureaux son concept un taxi
collectif de huit places qui permet de
vous déplacer à prix réduits comptait 2
euros maximum le trajet les explications
de mathilde de franco
l'objectif de cette start-up simplifier
la mobilité des habitants de leur
quotidien pour les jeunes sans permis de
conduire les personnes âgées ou les
personnes ne disposant pas de véhicule
les lignes de bus sont parfois une
véritable galère l'entreprise permet
donc aux murs y autant de se déplacer
dans des zones difficilement accessibles
en transports en commun à un coût réduit
le principe du service c'est qu'on a une
application mobile qui permet de
réserver le passage du véhicule en temps
réel ou à l'avance le véhicule va
s'arrêter à moins de 200 mètres de là où
vous êtes et va vous conduire à moins de
200 mètres de votre prêt d'arriver en
finale et ceci pour un prix maximum de 2
euros par trajet vannes oc lancé en 2019
et des buts depuis décembre ses premiers
essais dans la ville des mureaux grâce
au pôle territorial de coopération
économique afin que acteurs du
territoire nous avons initié un
programme le booster des entrepreneurs
pour
accompagner les porteurs de projets à se
lancer dans l'entreprenariat et nous
avons été ravis d'accueillir au vanneau
dans ce programme
kkr a été lauréat du
coup de coeur de la session booster le
service est disponible 7 jours sur 7 de
4 heures du matin jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin le lendemain c'est plus pratique
et complice est disponible à toute heure
et accueille deux heures de trop en
moins de 7 jours ci a besoin de quelque
chose faire quelque chose à faire un
rapide bain on prend 20 noms et on fait
ça arrive ça arrive vite un père de
corona tout ça qu'on vide les bus on est
plutôt regroupés alors que renault bas
il ya souvent une ou deux personnes
m'ont beaucoup le monde
l'autre objectif de la start up et de
diminuer l'empreinte carbone et la
congestion urbaine avec des trajets
collectif la course peut être commandé
en temps réel ou à l'avance via
l'application mobile vanot
[Musique]
là le plan france relance en soutien aux
associations de protection animale je
vous en parlais dans les titres la
préfecture des yvelines a lancé le 15
décembre dernier un appel à projets en
direction de ses associations ses
structures engagées dans ce domaine
peuvent candidater jusqu'au 31 janvier
2022 et pour en parler jean-bernard
baridon est avec nous par
vidéoconférence bonsoir
oui
on va en parler dans un instant jean
bernard baryton juste pour vous
présenter vous êtes le directeur de la
ddpp alors ceci que ça veut dire
direction départementale est de la
protection des populations des yvelines
on le disait dans les titres une
enveloppe de 1 million d'euros a été
attribuée dans le cadre de cet appel à
projets à akwa justement peuvent servir
ses financements alors il ya deux types
de financement possibles à une aide au
financement de la stérilisation de chat
ou de chien c'est un premier projet et
l'aide au financement d'acquisitions
immobilières de aux travaux de travaux
de réparation dans les refuges sous
réserve que ces refuges e préexiste lors
de la demande pourquoi soutenir les
associations qui oeuvrent justement pour
la protection animale pourquoi le plan
france relance prévoit un volet en la
matière écoutez il ya différentes
explications la première c'est que les
animaux qui sont en déshérence ou qui se
reproduit ce sont souvent des animaux
qui sont malheureux et vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une un objectif qui
est un objectif de de lutte contre la
maltraitance animale c'est le premier
pointe le deuxième point c'est aussi
pour limiter la stérilisation c'est pour
éviter les animaux errants et le
troisième point c'est pour donner aux
associations qui font des efforts on
s'occupait de cet animal je rappelle que
le le l'animal est un animal conscient
au sens de l'article l 214 euros
donc c'est de leur donner les moyens de
les aider à passer un cap parfois
difficile quand elles ont besoin d'être
outillés d'être équipé en matériel
divers et variés pour le bien-être
animal vous le rappeliez un sou travail
législatif qui a eu lieu avec ce projet
de loi qui a été adopté un sur le
bien-être animal or comment justement la
ddpp donc je le rappelle direction
départementale de la protection des
populations travail avec ces
associations de la protection animale
dans les yvelines tel est le travail
effectué alors le travail qui est
effectué est un travail de prévention
évidemment c'est aussi un travail de
collaboration et assistance puisque ces
associations peuvent aussi dans certains
cas nous aider lorsque nous avons besoin
d'exfiltrer des animaux qui ont été
maltraités ça c'est le travail au
quotidien pour en revenir spécifiquement
aux plans de relance il y à un certain
nombre de règles qui ont été définis qui
d'une part définissent les bénéficiaires
dont kylie a lésé des carnivores
domestiques et les équidés et qui
d'autre part définissent les conditions
d'éligibilité pour l'attribution des
aides qui s'adressent essentiellement
d'abord aux associations qui ont plus
d'une année de création dans le dossier
complet et qui nous présente des devis
le vit sur lesquelles celle à bord on
calcule ondes le montant de l'aide
attribuée un point particulier sur la
stérilisation des animaux nous prenons
en charge la moitié des frais
vétérinaires donc un travail qui est
effectué avec ces associations et vous
l'avez dit aussi dans l'élaboration des
dossiers pour répondre à cet appel à
projets c'est bien ça tu as fait et nous
avons également mené une campagne
d'information auprès des élus locaux
puisque les eaux du look ou sont au plus
proche de cette problématique de manière
à les alerter en existence de ce plan de
financement de façon à leur permettre
d'une part de répondre en temps réel des
associations qui décomptent a cure et
puis d'autre part de les renvoyer vers
le service instructeur la ddpp et
comment on comment seront elles
sélectionné ces associations sur quels
critères justement vous allez pouvoir
les départager les sélectionner en tout
cas ils auraient voté pour le moment je
dirais que les choses sont relativement
simples puisque nous avons une enveloppe
et que cette enveloppe n'a pas encore
été saturé nous prenons les dossiers au
fil nous examinons leur éligibilité
c'est là où c'est le plus difficile
puisqu'il faut que l'on s'assure
qu'elles remplissent bien des conditions
pour bénéficier des deux je rappelle
quand même que ce sont des aides
publiques donc il faut que nous soyons
légitime à les attribuer mais pour le
moment il n'y a pas de difficultés
particulières
l'accent est toutefois mis sur la
stérilisation des animaux de façon à
éviter une explosion de la demo qui par
définition n'ont pas de maître et qui
ont deux enfants ou qui auront du mal à
subsister ou à survivre dans un contexte
urbain difficile donc un appel à projet
qui est ouvert est lancé jusqu'au 31
janvier elle était landrier ensuite
avait coûté déjà à la vente de
calendriers je peux évoquer les mondains
éligibles puisque c'est sur demande
incluant variables qui peuvent aller de
2000 euros minimum trois cent mille
euros maximum le calendrier c'est
évidemment jusque jusqu'à la fin de ce
mois ci l'expérience prouve qu'il sera
possible probablement de détendre un
petit peu ce calendrier sur la fin du
premier trimestre et pour le moment nous
n'avons pas de difficultés particulières
pour traiter les dossiers les
récipiendaires sont traitées en temps
réel nous avons traité déjà d'ici au
titre de 2021 et aujourd'hui même
d'ailleurs j'ai reçu la dernière demande
d'une association ou stériliser des
déchets mais je parle de stérilisation
et je n'insiste bien il ya deux volets
il ya aussi amener de financement des
logos du matériel destiné à faire
fonctionner ses
services d'accueil des animaux sous
certaines conditions de jeu ne vais pas
ici et pour plus d'information justement
on peut se rendre sur le site de la
préfecture des yvelines qui s'affiche
qui va s'afficher en bas de l'écran
rendez vous dans la rubrique france
relance pour avoir toutes les
informations sur cet appel à projet qui
a été lancé merci jean bernard barré
d'endeavour est avec nous merci beaucoup
et je le rappelle directeur de la ddpp
la direction départementale de la
protection et des populations des
yvelines et on voulait profiter de cette
thématique pour faire un petit focus sur
l'association et requins qui accueille à
des animaux abandonnés venant de
métropole venant également à des
territoires et départements
d'outre-mer on vous proposera un peu
plus tard dans ce journal on fait face à
une petit problème technique et on vous
le proposera un peu plus tard dans ce
journal
[Musique]
avant ça donc la suite de notre dossier
de la rédaction consacrée aux élections
législatives au programme les 12 et 19
juin prochain territoire historique de
la droite la 10e circonscription des
yvelines était passé sous la bannière de
la république en marche en 2017 avec
l'élection de roland berger à cinq mois
du nouveau scrutin est quelle est la
situation et qui pourraient être
candidats ont fait le point ils étaient
15 sur la ligne de départ en 2017 horber
rejet s'était imposé pour le compte de
la république en marche dans la 10e
circonscription des yvelines une
victoire au second tour des élections
législatives face au député sortant de
l'époque jean frédéric poisson à cinq
mois du nouveau scrutin la parlementaire
n'a pas encore annoncé si elle serait
candidate pour un deuxième mandat cette
question s'il répondrait au bourg en est
le bon moment c'est après l'élection
présidentielle
et moi je souhaite que présente la
république soit à nouveau candidat je
ferais sa campagne à 100% même plus et
je ferai tout pour qu'il soit réélu
parce que je considère que c'est la
bonne personne au bon moment et que si
j'ai pu agir en faveur de nos
territoires c'est aussi parce que gérer
ce président de la république avec côté
réindustrialisation attractivité
mobilité seront parmi les enjeux de la
prochaine campagne selon la députée
sortante dans cette circonscription de
120 mille habitants l'identité du
territoire est essentiellement rural a
également une place prépondérante vient
pas habité par hasard dans une de ces
cinquante et une communes de ce
territoire c'est non pas la défense
d'une identité en maths village gaulois
il ne faut que rien ne bouge mais c'est
comment cette identité elle est une
force pour les habitants de ce
territoire services publics agriculture
aménagement du territoire toutes ces
thématiques doivent être prises en
compte au travers de l'écologie déjà en
lice en 2017 david j tiennent encore
rien décidé un nouveau profil pourrait
conduire la candidature d'europe
écologie les verts en alliance avec
d'autres mouvements de gauche l'élu
d'opposition à rambouillet croit en les
chances des victoires dans une
circonscription qui a été sous bannière
écologistes entre 2010 et 2012 c'est un
trait à un territoire sur lequel on est
implanté depuis depuis longtemps sur
lequel on
idée ne font que progresser ces
dernières années et vous l'avez constaté
on arrive
deuxième force politique derrière les
républicains lors des derniers des
derniers scrutins c'est vraiment le
programme écologiste qui est adapté à la
situation environnementale climatique à
la situation de la de la biodiversité et
que tout ça ça se décline dans des
propositions très concrètes c'est une
dixième circonscription le combat des
gilets jaunes a trouvé aussi incertaine
et qu il ne serait donc pas impossible
de voir émerger plusieurs candidatures
citoyenne l'une d'elles pourrait être
conduite par michael le saunier
fondateur du collectif des marcheurs
cueilleurs qui réfléchit à se lancer
dans la bataille des législatives
ancien soutien d' emmanuel macron est
proche d'horreur berger il se dit déçu
des promesses de renouvellement
politique et souhaite porter l'idée d'
écologie positive je trouve que notre
politique n'est pas satisfaisant pour
nos concitoyens et bat pour les côtoyer
tous les jours pour est énorme sur le
terrain je me rends compte qu'ils
attendent autre chose ils attendent qu
enfin ce soit des des citoyens venus un
peu d'eux alors de la base c'est assez
péjoratif mais voilà des vrais citoyens
engagés qui enfle et celle de porter au
niveau politique de nouvelles idées à
droite pour reconquérir la
circonscription les républicains
pourraient investir and cabri la mère
d'orson lille et conseillère régionale a
confirmé atv 78 qu'elle pourrait être
candidate reste à savoir ce que va faire
l'ancien député jean-frédéric poisson en
poste jusqu'en 2017 en alliance avec l
air le président de via la voix du
peuple soutient désormais et l'eczéma
moore pour la présidentielle les
élections législatives elles se
tiendront les 12 et 19 juin prochains le
sport et du tennis avec la deuxième
victoire d'arthur rinderknecht dans un
tournoi du grand chelem le saint
germanois abattu ce matin l'australien
alexei pau pyrénées au premier tour de
l'open d'australie succès difficile en
cinq sets 7-5 4-6 6-2 3-6 6-4 devant un
public plutôt hostile et vous le voyez
la laissait d'ailleurs exploser sa joie
au moment de la balle de match remportée
c'est la deuxième fois dans sa carrière
que le tennisman rejoint le 2e tour d'un
tournoi majeur après l'us open la saison
dernière le 48e joueur mondial
affrontera jeudi le britannique dan
evans tête de série numéro 24 et tombeur
du belge david goffin pour une place en
seizièmes de finale
une projection débat samedi dernier à
poissy l'association le champ des
possibles à organiser cette projection
autour du film animal réalisé par six
révisions qui est originaire de la ville
de poissy rendez vous accompagné d'un
temps d'échangé avec le jeune et vipul
and to madness varane protagonistes du
film et jeunes militants écologistes de
18 ans habitant de marly le roi le
reportage de céline charles et de
patrick jacques de dixmude avec le temps
on nous sommes coupés du monde sauvage
des animaux des forêts
a pris le succès de demain sur le
changement climatique animal sorti le
1er décembre 2021 s'attaque au sujet
délicat de l'extinction de masse et de
la biodiversité une projection unique
était offerte par l'association le champ
des possibles né en 2017 à la suite du
premier film empreint de chacune des
causes de l'extinction et on va essayer
de trouver une solution puis rapidement
on s'est aperçu que c'était plus
complexe que ça et qu'il y avait un
problème plus fondamental qu'on avait à
régler entre guillemets c'était là notre
relation au monde vivant et c'est en
comprenant mieux comment
fonctionne quelles sont les manières
propre d'êtres vivants des autres
espèces qu'on peut mieux cohabiter avec
les autres espèces j'ai pas été déçu
effectivement si le thème était la
biodiversité
j'ai été enthousiasmée à ça commence par
des images très dures mais ça finit par
des messages très forts plus est positif
et
maintenant il faut qu'on joue tous notre
rôle dans le film le réalisateur cyril
dion a effectué un tour du monde avec de
jeunes activistes de la génération
climat dont vip ulan plus vanessa rahn
qui a grandi à marley ils étaient
présents après la diffusion pour
échanger avec le public le but c'est
quand même de répondre aux attentes du
public aux questionnements qui peuvent
avoir qui va être particulier à
particulier en fonction d'eux des enjeux
locaux par exemple moi je pense qu'il
faut pas céder aux perspectives des
fonderies sts dans le sens où si on sait
hélas - on se dit bon bah c'est foutu
façon raisonnable de canal toute la
journée et puis voilà quoi donc moi
j'essaie de prendre chaque situation de
lutte chaque enjeu précis essayer de
voir comment on peut remporter la
victoire 68% des animaux sauvages
vertébrés ont disparu ces quarante
dernières années un film pour donner
envie de se mobiliser à son échelle
l'association propose quant à elle des
actions de limitation des déchets comme
des répères café de nettoyage citoyens
ou encore des actions de sensibilisation
artistique
s annonce
[Musique]
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure focus
à présent sur une association oeuvrant
pour la protection animale et qui a été
créé en 2019 rk s'occupe des animaux
abandonnés à l'accueil des animaux les
accueils pour ensuite leur trouver une
famille pour les adopter basée dans les
yvelines au tartre godrans elle fait
venir notamment des chiens ou des chats
des îles de la réunion et de la
guadeloupe ce jour là quatre chiens
arrivent de saint denis le reportage de
nicolas landry
là il est 7 heures et nous partons
hu à l'aéroport d'orly pour aller
récupérer quatre chiens en provenance de
l'île de la ring travaille beaucoup en
aide aux animaux des îles les chiens en
l'occurrence pour la réunion et chiens
et chats pour la guadeloupe parce que là
bas il ya beaucoup de maltraitance il
faut pas oublier que ce sont des îles
françaises et donc on récupère
énormément d'animaux des îles maintenant
ça nous empêche pas non plus de
récupérer des animaux en métropole bien
entendu
bonjour sa fait patate république
salue où tous
les jours
j'avais fait bon voyage
ça fait bien passer à la télé ou à la
donne et
ça c'est un petit coquin celui ci les
dix doigts tu fait un timide rebond
timide mais je te connais je t'ai vu mes
jambes photos
en tout cas merci
merci à monsieur europe merci au revoir
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là on a la maman des deux chiots
qui s'appelle qui nous conte à léo le
petit léo qui ont été trouvés dans la
fameuse cour d'école qui reviens de loin
oui ça c'est les deux pucci le king
donc on a qui a ré la petite noire et
blanche et nouba lotis l'autre petit et
caché là d'ailleurs voilà donc là
maintenant il ya une heure de route pour
aller à la villa derka donc dans ma
maison je les accueille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on coucou les plus petits bébés
coco tu viens
ils ont perdu leurs petits manteaux
année
ouais
[Musique]
là je vais sortir les chiens david ader
cas c'est à dire les miens j'ai deux
gros molosse qui accueille tous les
chiens qui arrive
voilà vous venez
depuis 2019 on a une super marraine on à
claude chirac qui a accepté d'être la
marraine de l'association
et puis oui on a de plus en plus on est
on nous approchent mais les écoles nous
approchent et cetera pour des projets
on a 380 chars qui ont été adoptées et
400 on doit être à 410 chiens-là
d'adopter alors là j'ai les
développements de koulouba qu'il arrive
il son portail
allez on y va on va voir ses parents
voilà je vous ai amené votre petit
bonhomme
bah oui c'est un changement de
température et certaines des pichous un
petit peu inquiets que j'ai pu ma petite
soeur
thébaux mais dans les bois il claque des
dents ont eu la copie il va s'appeler ce
nokia c'est difficle à chaque fois il a
deux mois et demi on a tout préparé on
doit préparer son panier s'échouer ses
p'tites gamelles et puis bon on va le
présenter à nos petits enfants à nos
enfants et puis voilà on va les pros
mais on va s'en occuper on va de choyer
allez on fera croiser un petit peu voilà
avant de vous laisser le plus bel arbre
de france et yvelinois le châtaignier de
la celle saint cloud a été plébiscité
par le prix du public du concours
organisé par le magazine terre sauvage
et l'office national des forêts situées
dans le quartier résidentiel de la ville
il serait âgé d'environ 330 ans et
aurait été planté sous le règne de louis
xiv et des photos du châtaignier seront
exposées à la gare de lyon du 20 janvier
au 20 mars il représentera la france au
concours de l'arbre de l'année européen
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant vous
avez rendez vous avec le 7-8 culture
présentée par célia agathe son go belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]